hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast more from less high-quality
data from low quality samples we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by perkin-elmer I am Julia
Oracle averse and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker Andrew very
director of product development and
marketing for the Broad Institute
genomics platform I will now turn it
over to Andrew Barry for his
presentation thanks Judy and thanks to
all for joining today so as Julie
mentioned I'm responsible for product
development within the Broad Institute
genomics platform and you know really
our goal is to provide our internal as
well as our external community with a
set of products and resources to produce
high-quality data and you know as we get
into the different breadth of
applications for which genomics is being
used you know we really need to expand
the the sort of threshold for which we
can accept samples and you know a lot of
the work that's gone on within the
burden stupid in genomics platform has
really been focused on you know
developing strategies for you know
making the most out of the samples that
we received and you know developing
strategies whether within a project or
across technology that really allow us
to produce the highest quality data we
can regardless of of what we get is the
input to the process so i'll be speaking
a little bit today about some of the
different strategies that we've employed
just moving on to the next slide I'll
give you a little bit of a background on
the Broad Institute itself for those
that might not know the bird Institute
on profit biomedical research Enterprise
that was founded in 2004 not by MIT
Harvard and its affiliated hospitals the
Whitehead Institute and our founders the
philanthropist UI and Edythe broad and
the goal is really to accelerate the
pace at which the world conquerors
disease we're located in in Boston
Cambridge actually one of the world's
most influential crossroads of academia
industry of medicine and we're bringing
together leading biomedical scientists
from our community again with the goal
to develop bold new ideas that address
the most urgent in vicious problems that
the world was trying to solve related to
human health really at the core of this
is a collaborative model this is between
you know our own researchers and the
hospitals that are within our community
external groups government agencies
philanthropic donors and really you know
again the goal is to create the
necessary models to take on some of
these ambitious challenges and we do
that with a very deeply collaborative
spirit we collaborate as broadly as we
can in one of our goals is to share our
methods resources and data with the
ultimate goal of enabling others to
accelerate discovery and we're
constantly looking for new ways in which
to disseminate learning and output of
our activities and get the information
that we're learning whether it be data
or methods or you know really exposing
some of our capabilities externally so
the others can leverage them with the
external community and trying to use
this as a means to to really help the
industry overall and you know anybody
that's interested in in advancing human
health so the genomics platform itself
it's a fairly big infrastructure and our
goal is to provide the high quality
genomic data to the scientific community
both internal as well as external and
really to facilitate some meaningful
conversations with the folks that are
using looking to leverage these data and
you know the goal there is to ensure
that we're continuing to develop the
right tools based on real world problems
that researchers are starting to use
genomics to solve and i think thats you
know really speaks to the need for
producing this high-quality data on to
low quality samples as we can because we
don't always have the luxury of using
our you know high quality and high
performing control samples when things
get turned on in a production
environment we
typically learn things from what learned
a lot more from the lower quality
samples than we do our you know what we
would use to typically develop the
process we pride ourselves on the scale
quality and speed at which we can take
on some of these ambitious projects and
you know we're really anxious to see
what types of questions folks have as we
sort of expand our horizons and take on
more in terms of what we're actually
able to interface with the outside world
with so you know I think part of our
culture here in the genomics platform is
we've really merged together sort of
industrial best practices and applied
those to genomics and we work closely
with the MIT Sloan School of Management
and benchmark ourselves against you know
a lot of external industrial best
practices and groups that have applied
you know things such as modular
automation process design work design
you know these these sort of aspects
being applied in a life sciences
genomics laboratory is sort of a novel
concept in which was it something we
pride ourselves on and really the goal
is to you know create a situation where
we can take existing technologies and
processes and perform some optimization
and the way that we do that is we
typically will take a process and break
it down to its individual components and
look at those individual process steps
and define what the inputs and outputs
of those are once we do that we can
actually start to optimize within those
process steps and then as we put these
things together what we find is that
we're able to develop a level of process
control that really helps us to you know
trust the processes that we're running
in terms of taking in raw sample and
turning that into genomic data this is
just an example that you know sort of
highlights this where you know starting
with a process where we're running
something manually and you know on the X
on the y-axis that's just a percentage
of unclassified reads which is you know
just a single proxy that we might use to
optimize something but you know once we
start to measure those things and apply
some of these techniques and really do
that sort of modular optimization within
these process steps we can what we find
is that we're able to generate you know
really higher quality data and we do
this through a lot of different
different tools so you know one is
sample tracking so making sure that
samples that enter our process we have
positive sample tracking as they move
through and that's something where you
know in this case we're showing a custom
consumable that we would use to take in
samples and be able to apply that with a
barcode and make sure that we have
tracking through our limbs you know so
at the end of the day when the data gets
produced it can be associated with the
correct sample information that we've
received building error proofing into
the process this is a concept poka-yoke
is the technical term for it but really
it's error proofing and creating you
know multiple checks and balances
throughout the process that allow us to
make sure that the right information is
being asked for and being entered into
you know fields that will later allow us
to go back and do some troubleshooting
should we need to and you know having
these types of this type of approach to
life sciences again it's something sort
of novel but really ends up having a
pretty big impact you know we think
about lab automation it's very integral
to what we do here and we believe it's
really a huge part of you know what we
would use to be able to do things at
scale at high quality we've taken a
modular approach to this where you know
rather than having a lot of different
things being being done on a single deck
with with you know a lot of different
inputs and outputs we tend to break
things down into their fundamental
processes in you know have a single
piece of automation doing a rather
simple task for doing that highly
repetitively we found that we can
generate some high scales with that and
then you know once we get all of this
information that we're collecting about
our process back on building some some
of these dashboards that allow us to
monitor processes and make sure that
they're actually in control and when
they're not be able to dig in deeper and
find out what the root cause of some of
those issues are so it's really a
combination of the lab processes being
able to capture the information up front
being able to take those in embed them
in a data warehouse and then at the end
of the day associate those with the
sequencing metrics that might be
associated pull those things back
together and develop some real-time
analytical tools and what we find is
that when we apply these things and this
is just a specific example you can see
that all of a sudden those that
percentage of unclassified reads goes
down dramatically and is a process
that's in much higher control so these
are the types of things that we would
they apply to any type of sample type
but when we start to look at more
challenging sample types typically they
force us to think outside the box a bit
and start to apply some some of these
techniques in a slightly different way
that is more specific to different more
challenging sample types just to give
you some information on the platform and
in some of the scale which we're
operating so we currently operate about
40 high seeks and those are those are
split between 2025 hundreds we have 10
my seeks single next week 500 and we
have 14 high seek X's or 1.4 x 10's
however folks typically think about that
these are just some of the numbers in
terms of the sort of throughput in terms
of you know this is from 2000 9 2014 I
haven't updated this with 2050 numbers
but you know over 120,000 exomes RNA
seek is really up ticked in the last
several years we're producing more human
genomes now than ever before to rated
about somewhere between 1500 and 2000
genomes per month in fact in the month
of October of 2014 we actually produced
a single human genome every 32 minutes
using the hi-c texts so those were being
run at full capacity and that's always
our goal is to run those at as high a
capacity as possible and fortunately
we've been able to achieve that over the
past several months we do a ton of
genotyping as well in terms of samples
stored you know we're collecting samples
from all over the world in different
formats so we have about 1.2 million
samples stored with the capacity to
store about another two-and-a-half to
three million on premise here on
premises here and then you know just
looking at the total output you know
that's that's 3,000 Terra basis so
that's three times ten to the fifteenth
basis so quite a large scale and
obviously a lot of this is enabled by
the advances in the sequencing
technology itself and you know we've
continued to sort of build the
infrastructure around those sequencers
to be able to do this at scale and to do
it reliably so we think about you know
how we interact with the outside world
really we think about we have
researchers that are sort of pis and in
the way that the bird is sort of
organized as
between what we call scientific programs
and scientific platforms so the right
way to think about a program is that
these are really the high-level
scientific questions that are being
asked in the science then the platform's
themselves are really that the nuts and
bolts and in the factories that live
within in different application and
technology areas that allow us to look
across those and use whatever tools we
need to apply to be able to answer the
right questions so that's the rodents to
genomics platform berta suit genomic
services is really our way of
interfacing this with the outside world
so this is really our way of taking the
things that are core capabilities and
making those available to the external
world so we do that through bird
Institute genomic services you can visit
our website at you know mixed up Road
institute org and really when we think
about that it's it's you know everything
from really transactional
fee-for-service products that you can
get a browser on our website and
understand the inputs and outputs of and
then there's you know really more custom
solutions where we're taking you know
different components of this and putting
them together to really you know address
a unique problem that might be specific
to a disease area or sample cohort that
that one is trying to study and then you
know in addition there situations where
you know maybe the technologies that
exist today don't quite give us what we
need to answer those questions and
that's where we engaged externally with
grips to you know build more deep
scientific collaborations and really
build something that's totally new to
the world so today we'll talk a little
bit about sort of the breadth of the
applications for which NGS did is used
and understand some of the sample
specific challenges in terms of
maximizing data quality for those and
then we're going to discuss some of the
strategies that we've employed here to
overcome sample quality with the goal of
improving that the data quality that
comes out of the sequencer is at the end
of the day so you know really when we
think about this we've broken this down
into sort of four discrete areas one is
really the nucleic acid extraction so
how we can take whatever the primary
material is and generate its high
quality nucleic acid as we can the next
is really the QC of that so how do we
look at these samples and number one
look at an assay that's going to give us
some information that's going to tell us
you know the quality inn
current quality and some of those in
terms of characteristics of the nucleic
acid and then really associate that
downstream with what the impact of that
is on sequencing data and what that
allows us to do is work with our
collaborators and pis and you know try
to understand what the path forward is
for some of those samples that you know
maybe are on the edge and you know maybe
we maybe we don't want to you know pass
on and spend more money to actually turn
that into genomic data and you know
somebody described us as to me as the
the watchful older sister that's you
know asking if do you really want to
date that guy because the sample looks a
little bit sketchy so that's sort of how
we think about some of those qcs and
really a lot of focus here has been on
the sample preparation strategies and
and how we take things from purified
nucleic acid and make sure that we can
deal with lower amounts but also lower
quality nucleic acid and still make sure
we can get the data through that tool
explore some of those and then some of
the sort of analytical approaches to
being able to you know compensate for
what might be lower quality data and
we'll discuss them some of the tools
that we use to help filter out some of
the information that might not be
helpful in terms of discovering new
variants some of the artifacts and then
also how we can actually use some of the
breadth of what we have in our own
experience to be able to compensate for
some of the lower quality data so we
think about what our core product
offerings are here really we think about
this as human whole genome sequencing
human whole exome sequencing human whole
transcriptome sequencing or RNA seek and
we also have a CLIA cap accredited lab
where we offer a technical exum with
either germline or semantic analysis and
it's important to know that for all of
these there are several of these these
are ffpe compatible technologies a lot
of the work that we're doing here is
focused on oncology so if you know
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded samples
are a very normal thing for us to
process here so you know a lot of work
has gone into fft but also some of the
other more challenging sample types that
we'll discuss so i think about what the
challenge example types we mentioned
ffpe and you know what some of the
challenges there are so you know
p tends to be degraded we have some
cross-linking happening there some
deamination events that might take place
oxidation based off of that as well as
challenges with low allelic fraction and
we'll discuss a little bit what the
impact of the allelic fraction will
actually have on the quality of the data
in the sensitivity that we're able to
achieve you know saliva is a
particularly challenging when we do
genome sequencing from saliva we
typically will see high levels or
varying levels of bacterial
contamination that can sometimes be
challenging to actually meet you the
coverage to the desired coverage to be
able to use in some of the downstream
analyses another example would be blood
where sometimes we see tumor in the
normal or for doing to a normal pairing
oftentimes blood has been normal and
sometimes what we see is that will
actually have you know some of the tumor
especially if it's if it's a blood-based
ailment that you know we actually have a
difficult time because there's actually
two men than normal so it's harder to
use for somatic analyses you know we
think about understanding and resolving
some of these more subtle artifacts from
the data one of the things that that you
know we've done a lot of work with is
with ffpe so so you know FFP as we
discussed will induce introduced lots of
different types of DNA damage
deamination is one of those so this is
where you know basically due to an
oxidation event will convert cytosine to
uracil and that's going to lead to when
we actually do PCR will actually see
that will have in mrs. and corporations
and what we've done is taken a step back
and built some tools that actually flag
some of these artifacts as artifacts and
that really is going to help us sort of
differentiate the artifacts from a true
false positive or an actual variant then
those are actually part of our standard
outputs now we're you know part of the
Picard pipeline actually will develop
some of these metrics and actually
output them and it's really important
for us because you know when we're
introducing a new process now we have
another thing that
want to make sure works and you know
we're always looking at some of these
values and making sure that they're not
creeping up because you know they're the
type of thing that can creep in one of
the prime examples of this was actually
in our DNA sharing which I'll get into
it in a few minutes but you know we
actually saw this start to creep up and
you know we're able to overcome it
fairly easily but but it's one of those
things where if you're not looking
forward is something that's going to
creep in and can really cause some
confusion at the end of a study where
you know all of a sudden you're trying
to whittle down to the real causal
variants and now you have this list of
things that are really artifacts that
are going to going to be prohibited from
from drawing more logical conclusions we
talked about the impact of allele
fraction on variant detection so you
know really when we think about allele
fraction it's the fraction of DNA
molecules that come from a locus that
carry a mutation so when we're dealing
with FFP obviously what we're trying to
accomplish is you know getting the most
cells in there that are actually when
we're doing to my normal pairing for
semantic analysis we're actually you
know really anxious to interested in
getting the majority of those cells that
are going to have the the mutation
present within the copies that we're
putting into the downstream analysis and
you know that figure on the Left which
will show you the output after some
optimization but you know you can see as
we go from for instance for the yellow
line to the red line on the on the
y-axis there is the actual sensitivity
to detect single nucleotide variants and
what we see is that you know as we drop
in that allelic fraction you really
start to get to the point where it's
going to become very difficult and
there's some things that will discuss
that we can do to overcome this but it's
important to understand and I think
there's a need for newer technologies to
be developed to really make sure that
we're doing a good job up front between
pathology and nucleic acid extraction to
make sure that we're getting the highest
percentage of tumorigenic cells into our
prep but we'll talk about some
strategies that we've employed to
overcome those as well we mentioned the
impact of material bacterial
contamination saliva samples we see this
typically for on a collection to
collection basis you know this is
obviously this is worse when we see
things from a more consumer genomics
approach
because you know proper protocols aren't
necessarily being in here too and what
basically this is bacteria from the malt
that actually ends up into into you know
the extraction and downstream sequencing
so you know you might have a situation
where you have you know somewhere
between you know forty and sixty percent
of the reeds are actually going to be
derived from bacteria which if you're
trying to hit you know 30x mean coverage
on your genome it makes things fairly
difficult to achieve because you're
going to have to keep sequencing and
sometimes may never get there just based
on the inherent contamination that takes
place with these events so now we'll
shift gears a little bit and start to
talk through some of the various
strategies that we've employed here to
overcome lower quality samples so
starting with nucleic acid extraction
we've done a ton of optimization around
the different nucleic acid extraction
chemistry's and you know we mentioned
kind of the process where we take things
and break them down to their fundamental
parts one of the technologies that we've
employed here for DNA extractions uses
the contingent technology these are this
is a magnetic bead based approach where
you know we see advantages because the
qiagen technology itself will it's an
electromagnetic rod as opposed to
pipetting so we're able to maintain some
of the integrity typically when we
pipette things through you know some of
the narrow bore pipette tips what you
actually are inducing there is our
shearing mechanisms for the nucleic acid
so what we found is that by using the
qiagen technology were able to get
higher quality nucleic acid out of that
and we've applied that to a very
challenging sample type which is dried
blood spots and cannot reliably get
enough material a lot of our drive led
us to go to some red downstream
application so you know seeing this
let's just kind of gives you an idea of
the breadth of applications and the
different types of you know primary
sample materials that were able to you
know generate high-quality data of from
you know based on the input that's
provided to us we we also have developed
a fairly comprehensive suite of RNA
extraction products as well as a series
of extraction products that will
actually take the same sample and
produce both DNA and RNA so we will end
up with enough material from a single
you know section of FFP or a single
group of sections from a single block of
FFP that aren't mutually exclusive in
the sense that you know my DNA isn't
going to be exclusive my DNA quantity
isn't going to be exclusive of the RNA
quantity so we're able to generate you
know both high-quality DNA and
high-quality deep RNA at the same time
from the same sample which is really
beneficial and we'll talk about some
applications where actually we'll start
with the same sample and put that into
downstream both DNA sequencing and RNA
sequencing and actually can draw some
pretty cool conclusions out at the end
of the day so moving on to nucleic acid
quality control this is where we've
spent a lot of time really building out
assays and in working with folks in the
industry to build out some of these
assays that allow us to really assess
some of the intrinsic characteristics of
the nucleic acid so we're looking at
things here like the concentration sighs
the degradation that might take place
there as well as you know really
understanding how much goes into those
downstream processes and making sure
that there's the the amount that you're
putting into those is normalized and
what we find is that by putting in you
know the same amount of nucleic acid
into some of these processes you're able
to get more reproducible results out on
the back end so one of the most useful
acids that we use here is an actual it's
a qpcr assessment of degradation we use
a kit from Kappa biosystems and
basically the way this works is we take
three different sized amplicons in
perform qpcr across those and what we
have worked with them to develop is
would look at this concept of a Q score
so what the Q score does is it looks at
the different ratios an abundance of the
different amplicons that we've created
and what we can do is sort of look at
that and tell what how much degradation
is actually there in the sample how much
how much material is actually capable of
being pcr amplified and what that allows
us to do is you know have a prediction
of you know how well this thing is going
to actually produce high quality data
and that's what you see in this bottom
right figure here where we actually can
predict the probability of success based
on this camp
you see score where you know certain
samples will just not attempt because we
know that it's not going to produce a
high-quality data to do anything useful
with so again this is something that we
often have an interaction with our
collaborators or customers on and are
able to feed that information back and
allow them to say you know either go
ahead with the sample and you know I
understand I'm not going to get high
enough data quality out of that or you
know really give them confidence that
they're a sample cohort is going to
produce high-quality data at the end of
the day and we can see the impact that
this has on he on the output so on the
x-axis here what you see is these are
all different types of FFP samples that
we've put into this process and in
similar to when we discussed the saliva
and bacterial contamination these do
tend to vary based off of the actual
collection itself and you know what we
found is that the actual quality that
we're able to get out at the end of the
day is actually less to do with anything
related to the age of the FFP block that
we're extracting nucleic acid and
sequencing from but more to do on a
collection to collection basis so you
know just something that we've observed
and you can see that you know after we
implemented that to see we're able to
generate much higher quality data with
the sample cohorts that we're putting
through the other assets that we will
run actually use the perkinelmer lab
chip GX technology so this is where we
will actually take a look at the size of
the nucleic acid and actually look at
this genomic quality score which is a
single metric that's attributed to
nucleic acid so this is an
electrophoretically separated assay
where we're taking the DNA separating
and then actually looking at the size
that's being achieved there and you know
developing this Q score allows us to
boil that down so what you see on the
bottom there is actually an experiment
where there was a degradation of nucleic
acid and we're able to see the
corresponding drop in in the Q scores
associated with that so that's something
that we'll use often times if we really
are a suspicious about a sample and one
know you know exactly how degraded it is
before we put it into any of the
downstream of processes similarly for
RNA I think the Rin is
a typical acid folks will use for for
general RNA quality the perkinelmer GX
is what we use here that has an analog
rqs or an RNA quality score that's
roughly the same calculation that would
take place in the glen what we find is
that for more challenging in particular
FFPE samples it's it's this new score
this DV 200 is actually a more accurate
predictor of downstream success so what
we're looking at is what is the the
population of fragments that are greater
than 200 base pairs and and we can
actually calculate that based on the
electropherogram of separating the RNA
out in the electro faretta capillary
capillary so you know really we do a
smear analysis and we're able to output
that and you know again we're using this
to predict what will happen in some of
the techniques that were employing to do
FFP RNA sequencing from fsp material
really rely heavily on on this as a
gauge to make sure that we're going to
you know again have a good predictor of
success downstream again this ass is
super easy to use and we can do this at
high scale and it to the point where you
know we can just click a button and
output a single metric that's going to
allow us to use as a as a hard and fast
cut off so we usually set the cutoff at
about 30 and down on the bottom right
you can actually see what the
correlation is between that DV 200 score
and the actual yield that we're going to
get out of our library prep and that
also correlates to something that we
always look at which is the percent
duplication so you know typically when
we do PCR what we find is that if we
have low input or degraded samples going
into PCR will get higher rates of
duplication happening so if we look at
the the DB 200 score relative to percent
duplication we typically see those two
things inversely correlated where you
know the higher the DB 200 the better
our are the worse are duplicated the
better of duplication is in terms of
lower lower duplication values so
shifting gears to sample preparation
protocols so this is really where we're
talking about taking the output of our
nucleic acid extraction with these more
challenging materials and putting them
into some downstream processes and I'm
going to get them ready for sequencing
so that you know really when you look
our product input requirements we're
trying to minimize these and I'll just
you know mention that the minimum
required DNA amount that you see there
that's actually 1.5 times what we
actually will use so we like to give
ourselves two attempts just in case
something goes wrong so these are the
amounts of nucleic acid that we actually
will ask for in terms of guaranteeing
that the results will be good based off
of this so if we if we take the samples
and actually assay them and generate
this material we can guarantee that the
data will actually produce the specified
deliverable for a different product so
you know you see that those are
relatively low across you know 250
nanograms so that means we're actually
taking 100 nanograms into the downstream
process the sort of one outlier here is
PCR free human whole genome sequencing
we asked for 1.2 micrograms that's
actually a 500 and a gram input and
we're working hard to reduce that
because we're really happy with the
performance of pcr for human whole
genomes as our collaborators to the
cleanliness of the data in terms of
variant calling as well as you know
eliminating any issues that we have with
with based specific bias so one of the
techniques that we've employed here is
really do with the fundamental library
prep and this paper was published I
guess about three years ago but still
gets used routinely here what you see on
the right there is a figure that sort of
describes the innovation that we apply
here so this is where you know we're
doing purification cleanups mid process
so in between some of the enzymatic
steps typically what we'll do is a bead
based purification we use a spry
technology where basically we bind
nucleic acids to these iron core
carboxylated beads and we're able to do
a couple things they were able to
concentrate or you know adjust the
concentration of samples as they
navigate we also want to purify away any
active enzymes or you know
unincorporated you know things like all
the nucleotides and then you know the
other thing that we're able to do with
this is an actual size based cut off so
we're able to actually based on the
concentration of some of the buffers and
we use a polyethylene glycol buffer
there and based on the salt
concentration in the concentration of
the peg that's in the buffer were able
to adjust the molecular weight of the
fragments that get carried forward in
the reaction so that the novel
innovation here was you know typically
these things happen serially and there's
a lot of steps that take place where
there's actually result in a lot of
sample transfers between different lab
receptacles what we've done is actually
eliminate those transfers this involves
actually leaving the beads in the well
during some of the enzymatic reactions
they don't inhibit the reaction that
we've done a lot of work to to make sure
that's true and and you know they give
you the added benefit because every time
you're going to pipette things out of
one receptacle whether it's a test tube
or a 96-well plate you're going to leave
behind some material there but so just
by leaving them the beads in the well
and being able to do your reactions
where you're you know based on the
buffer concentration you're either
binding to the beads or eluding off of
them you're able to do it all within the
same well and that allows us to do
really the entire sample for our
protocol on a single well which again
reduces those transfers and in results
in much higher yield so you know even if
we're starting with lower input we're
able to carry more of that material
forward downstream in the process and
that's what allows us to take in some of
these lower quality samples and still
generate high-quality data we talked a
little bit about some of these subtle
artifacts in our data so this is a
specific example that we were looking
into and this is really that this
oxidation that was taking place during
mechanical shearing so this is on the
cove iris instrument and what we were
able to do is actually look at this in
there's a publication based off of this
that you see down the bottom there but
what you know really what this was was
we're introducing these artifacts into
our sequencing data and we found out it
was it was basically because of the
buffer that we were using to shear in it
was again a very easy thing to overcome
by adding GBTA which the QA ting agent
into there so that was prevented able to
prevent the oxidation from happening as
it was able to bind some of those metal
ions but but you know it's one of those
things that you know if you're not
looking forward to really creep into
your data and it's something that again
now we look for across everything so you
know right now for looking for example
to introduce a new d paraffin ization
solution for FFP this is something that
we want to make sure you know isn't
inducing any of these types of artifacts
because we've seen it in various buffers
that we use for some of the exome
capture protocols and have done a lot of
work to optimize to make sure that we're
not introducing some of these artifacts
moving forward and you can see the
impact that we have on the sequencing
results so this oxidation Q score again
this is something that's part of the
standard output of the Picard pipeline
but something that will track and make
sure that were you know mitigating any
impact that might happen the impact I
mean whole exome sequencing is for a
long time been really the bread and
butter of a lot of the sample processing
here we developed you know really the
first scalable method for this and in
working with Agilent sure select to
develop that chemistry but also
automating it and doing it at scale I
mentioned earlier but we've done over
120,000 exomes here that's been sighted
in over 3800 publications and you can
see the impact that that has here and I
think you know specifically when we look
at some of these things you know one of
the things that that is really impactful
so you know january two thousand eleven
we would ask for 500 nanograms now we
can actually look at this and that's
more like 15 anagrams input and we're
always asking for more than we actually
will take but which we know we can push
the limits down and still produce high
quality data while doing things like
increasing the scale and reducing the
failure rates ago their associated with
those one of the other things that we've
really done here is is you know we've
introduced a new design for our ex home
and you know it's if you aren't
targeting some of the bases that are
really interesting to you you can't
expect to get high quality data from
those so we've done a lot of work to
really optimize the bait design for
exome sequencing to make sure that we're
getting the best coverage that we can so
we recently introduced and validated
lumina custom exim is what we call it or
ice so it's a new design for us it's
using the alumina chemistry so it's two
subsequent hybridization and captures
which provides us with very clean data
it's a 38 megabass bait set we've done a
lot of work to really optimize that in
terms of you know covering some of these
more challenging regions that we've
learned from our past experience one of
those things that we've done to optimize
that is improving the coverage
uniformity across targets with different
GC contents so what you see here on the
left is looking at two different our old
exome and our new exome and what we see
is that you know for things that are
higher gcing medium GC and low GC were
actually able to you know on the left
side of that red dotted line there for
the hi GC we're able to have far less of
those things showing up with very low
coverage and what that means is that you
know if we have challenging samples we
have a better chance of actually being
able to generate high-quality data
because we're actually bathing and
targeting those regions you can see this
is just an igg view of a particularly
difficult target this is a Puig but
we've gone back in and adjusted the bait
designed to really make sure that we're
getting out of a quick coverage so you
know the new you can see we have more
than adequate coverage across that where
the old we were missing that all
together not all together but when we
think about the distribution of depths
this is an analysis that we performed
where you know we're comparing the
average steps of coverage and what you
can see on the right there is that with
the new we're getting a much much higher
percentage of our targets are sorry much
lower percentage of our targets under
where we feel like our cutoff should be
to be able to call the right types of
variants that we're looking to use
downstream so you know overall it's it's
a better performing date and the impact
that we see there is is you know this is
going back to the figure that I'd shown
at the beginning of the presentation but
it really the impact on the sensitivity
that we're able to achieve is really
where you know sort of the rubber hits
the road in the sense that you know
again these colors will correspond to
the allele fraction going into this or
the percentage of the cells that are
actually
inherently mutagenic that are actually
holding the variant so again you know we
looking at specifically between this red
and yellow and the old excellent design
versus the new exome design but having
better coverage and more even coverage
we're able to you know again with the
same amount of data have a higher degree
of sensitivity for things like like
single nucleotide variants this is an
example where we're actually looking at
some whole exome sequencing and whole
genome sequencing data from ffpe and are
actually looking at you know how many
variants we can call between known and
false positive so we're able to see that
you know with whole exome sequencing
well we're not getting quite that the
number of variants that will get with
whole genome sequencing we're able to do
pretty good considering we're only
targeting you know one to two percent of
the genome so you know really just a
nice demonstration to show that we're
able to generate you know relatively
high quality data from ffpe and really
the FF II is not a limitation in terms
of the ability to produce that quality
copy number variants is something that
we're doing a lot of work with currently
to sort of optimized and be able to do
as reliably as possible this is showing
a canonical mdm2 amplification and whole
exome sequencing and whole genome
sequencing and you know whole genome
sequencing you can see that we're able
to find this much better but it's still
there in the exome sequencing and again
this is you know something that's really
hard to do which is called copy number
aberrations from whole exome data from
FFPE samples so you know it's a sort of
the worst case scenario and yet we're
still able to find some of these types
of variants that are really deemed to be
causal with some of the different types
of studies that were undertaking here
shifting gears to RNA one of the more
recent introductions from a product
standpoint is what we call transcriptome
capture so what this does is basically
takes RNA does a cdna prep a
complementary DNA prep from that and
then what we do is actually expose that
to a hybridization event or like an
excellent pull down we're basically what
we're going to do is select the bases
that are known transcripts and we
actually use the same bait design that
we do for our exone but then we're able
to do sort of differential express
analysis based off these data and this
works very well with with relatively low
Rin scores and again we're using the DV
two hundred metric as a cut-off up front
of this but it's really useful coming
out of fft because now we can take FS PE
and we can look at both you know exome
data and then orthogonal e look at the
RNA sequencing data that's associated
with that will actually i'll show you an
example that in just a moment one of the
things that we were happy is that we can
actually detect some fusion transcripts
with this and actually we do that as
well as a typical poly a selection so
you know this is comparing this
transcriptome capture protocol to a
standard Tru see polly a selection where
we're using an all of the dt approach to
pull out the RNA mrna transcripts
instead of enriching for them with this
the selection of them and what we see
here is that we're able to get you know
relatively similar or better a fusion
detection with this glue this protocol
as we would with a more standard RNA
sequencing approach even if we're coming
out of FFP and here's a great example of
the utility of this so this is something
that was published last month and you
know basically what we did is we took FP
tissue and looked at that in the goal of
this was to map sort of therapeutic
resistance in colorectal cancer but
basically what we did is had a sample
from you know pre therapy post the first
drug one but proved drug two and then
post drug too so were able to map sort
of the exilim variants that you see on
the left there where we can you know
they're all of a sudden in the post drug
to we start to see a que wrasse mutation
to rise and sure enough when we go on
the right there and look at that we're
able to see that with the transcriptome
capture protocol we're able to look at
overexpression of k Raths post drugging
so we're able to look at you know
mutation variants and then differential
expression to understand that you know
there's there's a mutation happening on
the deal at DNA level but you know sure
enough that actually is impacting the
transcription and we're able to sort of
you know understand that and use that to
map some of these resistance mechanisms
so moving on to some of the analytical
approaches
that will employ here to really deal
with the data once it comes off of the
sequencer there's a number of different
strategies that we've employed in you
know to sort of overcome some of the
inherent challenges that might result
from having lower quality samples as the
input to the process you know one of
those things is really understanding
resolving those subtle artifacts when we
talk about some of those oxidation
events our variant calling tool mutex
we've actually built some of the filters
for the different types of D emanation
induce artifacts so when you're looking
at those two plots the yellow is really
where we're looking at the specific CTB
emanation artifact and what we see is
that you know post filtering and just
this is a bit of an eye chart so I
apologize on the left that y-axis is the
top of the y-axis is at 12 whereas on
the right that y axis is at four so you
know what we see is that we're able to
sort of vastly reduce the number of
false positives that are being that are
resulting from these artifacts and again
this is a function of knowing what to
look for building the right filters
upstream and incorporating that into
your variant caller so you're not
calling these artifacts as actual
positives another great example of using
some of our informatik tools to overcome
this this is actually something that we
did the end of last year so we were
involved in a large clinical research
project in the goal was to identify some
variants in tumor normal pairs and you
know this was specifically a blood
disorder so we were using bone marrow
aspirate as the tumor but the normals
were blood in you know we started to run
some pilot samples and what we realized
was you know some of our the folks
looking at the data said you know we
actually are seeing the tumor in the
blood normal which you know isn't
unexpected given the fact that it was
actually a blood ailment so you know one
of the things that we benefit from here
is having a relatively large
computational biology and tool
developers so we have a lot of these
tools that are kind of in our research
space wouldn't necessarily be applied in
our CLIA lab but what we were able to do
is actually look at a specific tool and
this is the specific tool is called
Deaton that the 10 is for tumor and
normal and what that actually is able to
do is basically look at the reeds and
and be able to look at the allele
fraction that's associated with some of
those and be able to actually understand
the level of tumor that's present in the
normal and what we were able to do is
get this validated in our clinical lab
in time for this project the impact that
that had is we're able to do some some
correction but we actually didn't use it
for that purpose we used it to actually
filter the samples to make sure that the
sample pairs because this was a clinical
project and had some some implications
we wanted to make sure that the samples
that we chose for that project actually
were giving us the best quality somatic
variants zone at the end of the day so
you know by using that as a filter to
decide which samples we include we're
able to draw better statistical
conclusions out of the data that was
produced so this is again just another
example of applying some filters that
we've developed here to be able to
identify some of these things that could
otherwise cause complications downstream
another way that we're able to overcome
this is just buy some of the experience
that we have here so one of the things
that we do here is a concept called junk
variant calling and this is this is
something that's a function of the DAT k
haplotype caller so really what we're
able to do here is overcompensate for
areas where we might have lower quality
or lower coverage in certain regions
based on you know intrinsic qualities of
the nucleic acid what we do is we
actually will look at when we're
actually processing these in our
pipeline what we do is actually per site
variant calls and what that allows us to
do is differentiate between a homeless
true homozygous reference and you know
what we would otherwise call as you know
potentially a false positive because we
had lower coverage or false negative
excuse me because we have low coverage
and you know basically by looking at
other data that we have available that
might be within a single cohort it might
be you know across sample cohorts we're
able to use evidence from those and sort
of boost our confidence and being able
to reduce these overall false positive
rates so this is something that we can
do again with innocence within a sample
cohort to look at evidence of mutations
and use that to statistically understand
whether what we're seeing is actually a
real variant or something that you know
is a function of not having enough
coverage in a specific region that you
know could be the result of having lower
quality samples so just to get into some
overall results to wrap up a little bit
so we've run you know over the last five
years we've run over 5,600 FFP Drive
samples and that number is actually
increased since the slide was put
together you can see we've done that
across a variety of different downstream
applications and we're able to see a
very high level of success in terms of
meeting deliverables and those liberals
will vary based on the actual protocol
but those are things that we specify
upfront in terms of meeting a specific
percentage of targets for exome
sequencing at a given coverage we're
able to actually achieve that at a
relatively high success rate despite the
fact that we're working with in some
cases very low quality samples there's a
publication that I would recommend
pointing tuned for further readings was
published last year so this is where
we're looking at some of the tools that
we've employed here for whole exome
sequencing and clinical interpretation
of FFP sample tumor samples to guide
precision cancer medicine and what you
can see on the bottom there is that you
know really you know when we're looking
at some of these equality metrics that
we use to gauge the success of
sequencing what you see in the orange
and the red are FFP derived what you see
in the other colors are you know some of
the other sample types that we typically
use input and you know what you can see
there is really no correlation between
the FFP it's really more function of the
other things that are happening and it
might actually rise and lower quality
sequence data so you know I think you
know by putting all these things
together we're able to overcome some of
the inherent challenges from dealing
with lower quality samples and generate
data that we can we can actually draw
some logical conclusions from so in
summary you know some of the strategies
that we've employed to overcome sample
quality we talked about nucleic acid
extraction technology some of the
automation that we've employed there as
well as optimization of some of those
processes the sample QC so being able to
look at our samples measure the
intrinsic qualities use that as a
cut-off and a predictor of downstream
success some of the different sample
preparation strategies that we've
employed to overcome low quality samples
and then some of the analytical
approaches which we're using to sort of
filter out some of the issues that we
deal with on the data analysis
so with that I'm happy to answer any
questions and thank you for your
attention thank you for that informative
presentation before get started on the
question and answer session I'd like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window try to answer as
many questions as we can and our first
question is can the Commission which
uses a magnetic bead technology be used
to improve this protocol so yeah there's
a few advantages to using the qiagen
technology and I think it would depend
on the specific protocol that was being
used there you know one of the
advantages from came in technology is
that we're able to deal with relatively
high volumes of blood so that wouldn't
be a situation where it would be low
quality sample but because of the sort
of intrinsic nature of adding the beads
the primary sample and then using the
electromagnetic rods to be able to
actually separate out nucleic acid from
the other cells that are present within
that there there are some advantages
there the other advantages I mentioned
is you know by using this magnetic rods
as a means to separate you know magnetic
beads from from solution instead of
pipette tips you're not introducing any
additional shear forces where you know
really if you take a 40 kb DNA fragment
and you know pipette it up and down a
few times you gonna induce some sharing
there and will actually result in lower
lower lower molecular weight nucleic
acid as a result of just by petting that
and the shear forces that are created
from that okay looks like we have time
for one more question can this sample
protocol be used to analyze copy number
variation in non exone regions um so I
guess it would depend on the specific
sample preparation protocol certainly I
think any advantage that you're going to
get from using some of the strategies
that we've employed there are only going
to help your ability to call copy number
aberrations excellent sequencing as I
mentioned is particularly challenging in
the sense because you're only targeting
a subset of the genome in general and
some of
the ability to discern some of those
copy number variants is really a
function of the data that you're putting
into it so you know if you're only
targeting one percent of the genome and
there's only a certain percentage of
specific if you're in that you know I
typically separate this based off of you
know copy number detection so the
discovery of novel copy number variants
versus identification of copy number
variants so it would be easy to target
some of these known copy number variants
what becomes difficult with exome data
is the discovery of novel copy number
variants so actually we're working on
some tools here and looking to employ
those you know for production that will
actually allow us to do a better job of
calling copy number variants from exome
data but certainly all strategies that
were discussed here today would only
help to improve your ability to detect
those great I would like to thank our
sponsor perkinelmer for making today's
educational webcast possible today the
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November 13 2 2015
you'll receive an email from lab root
forwarding you in this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
and we have missed today's live event
see you next time goodbye